in less than 15 minutes you're going to
be able to replicate this in arcade 26.
what's going on guys my name is David
Thomas I'm a registered architect here
in Western Australia and today I'm going
to teach you exactly how you can
replicate this beautiful beach home in
arcad 26. before we get into it and we
actually break this down step by step I
wanted to thank over 2 000 of you that
have gone ahead and downloaded the free
archicad shortcuts template available on
the website now because of this
overwhelming demand and support I've
decided to actually go ahead and take
this one step further so the next couple
of weeks you're going to see something
magical appear on this desk but it is
available right now on the David
thomas.com now I'm not going to sell any
more of that let's dive straight into
this tutorial so first of all we're
gonna see on the left hand side we have
our image that we are going to be
replicating it is very simple it is very
easy to understand it is basically one
box with another box on top of it and
glass walls around it what makes it
creative and unique is the actual
materials and modeling so we're going to
try to do this as quickly and easily as
we can so I'm going to start this by
pressing command 7 because I'm on Mac
I'm going to insert a new story below
I'm going to call that footings and I'm
going to go minus one seven two you can
go minus whatever you want it's just the
typical thickness of a concrete slab
here on ground now I'm also going to
untick all of those on the right hand
side they made nothing in this video
just force of habit later down the track
so now we press OK and double click on
our footings layout to go directly to
our footings what I'm going to do next
is click on our slab tool I'm going to
open up our settings by pressing command
T which will open up all of our slab
settings you can see by clicking on this
section here that it opens up all the
predefined concrete slabs so in this
instance we have 150 millimeter ground
slab with tile finish on top for me
that's perfect in this instance I'm
simply going to press OK and move on to
this tutorial I don't really want to
focus too much on those elevation
markers so I'm going to hold my scroll
wheel come across and then I'm going to
Simply start by drawing a rectangle now
this rectangle is quite large in the
overall scheme of things so what I'm
going to do is go 30 meters by 10 meters
by simply typing that in now you see
we've already created our first
structural element next we're going to
double click on the ground floor right
click on footings and go show as Trace
reference which will show our footings
layer immediately below now what you'll
notice is if you need to come up top to
window then come down to pallets you're
also going to need to come down to trace
and reference that'll automatically open
up a new window which we can drag and
drop into our workspace so if we toggle
this little square on and off it'll
toggle our Trace reference on and off as
well now looking at this picture what
we'll see is there is basically two
levels there is a ground floor that's
entirely glass there is the first floor
that is predominantly cladding and just
a small piece of glass here and there so
let's start with our wall tool open up
our settings command T again let's try
find something that we're going to be
happy to work with there's a series of
predetermined wall types and wall
Composites it doesn't really matter what
you select in this instance because
we're not building it so for me I'm
simply just going to select the 90
millimeter insulated stud partition and
press OK next I'm going to click once
scroll into my corner to make sure I've
accurately selected that corner press
the P button to flip that wall around
and then continue all the way around
whilst holding shift to make sure my
walls are drawn dead straight now if we
press Escape go to our Marquee tool
Marquee that square right click show
Marquee in 3D we'll see that we've
automatically started to draw some
shapes in 3D what we will notice is that
our slab and our walls are not aligned
so what we're going to do is Select our
slab press Ctrl or command D for David
click on one of the hot spots and move
it up to the walls now let's double
click on our ground floor plan click
escape a few times select all of our
walls Ctrl C to copy double click on our
first floor plan Ctrl V for victory to
paste click away from that come back
into our 3D Marquee and there we go we
have another layer very rapidly created
on top let's go back to our ground floor
plan now and start modeling some windows
around if we treat this face as the
front that we're looking at and that is
the back we can basically mirror and
replicate it I'm just going to Simply
assume that it is identical all the way
around so let's go into our window tool
open up our window settings and create
the first window at the very front of
this elevation let's start by typing in
window up top in the search toolbar it's
going to give us window 26 which is one
of the simplest and easiest Windows to
use in this instance override these
horrendous orange lines that I can't
stand even looking at throughout this
project object and then remodel our
windows to the right size so overall
let's click OK and model this in 3D so
if we drop one of these windows in here
at the front of our building we'll see
it's quite a small window realistically
the width of that window is probably
about two meters if not even more let's
say that's two and a half meters all the
way across so we can either change that
up the top we can click command T and
change that in this top setting here or
we can simply adjust one of the hot
spots and drag it out as we need to now
this window is also probably about five
meters tall if not more so let's change
that to five meters tall now we want to
Center this window to the center of this
wall let's first start by highlighting
and selecting the window command D or
Ctrl D for David again to reposition it
and then find the center of your wall if
we go back to our 3D Marquee to see what
this is starting to look like we can
spin around to our other wall and we can
see it is don't Overkill and there's
some problems occurring so let's break
this down a little bit further let's
reduce that window size to two meters
and let's reduce the overall height two
let's call that
three and a half meters we also want to
drop the seal straight down to zero not
900 and then we can increase our window
to four meters because that window is
going to cut across we're going to
continuously edit this window as we go
across because it is the main feature of
the house but what you'll see here is
this top wall is basically not
intersecting with this window now the
easiest way to fix this problem is to
delete that wall select the ground floor
version and extend the leaf to the top
then we want to open up our settings by
going command T and show all stories on
floor display we want to select show all
relevant stories and press ok now if we
come to a ground floor plan we'll see it
in our ground floor plan if we go to our
first floor plan we'll also see that
window in our first floor plan coming
back down to our ground floor plan we
want to duplicate this window so let's
start by pressing command D then tapping
the option button to duplicate that
window as we move it across and move it
300 millimeters to one side we want to
repeat that same step on the other side
which gives us three identical Windows
coming back into 3D you'll see that
we've created those three identical
Windows very similar to what we see in
the image now what I'm understanding is
this house is significantly narrower
than I originally Drew so what I want to
do is Select my outside wall and reduce
that by let's say 1200 millimeters I
want to repeat that same step all the
way around and on both floors when I've
done that I want to select my four walls
again press command I for igloo and it
will automatically intersect those walls
now coming back into 3D we can see that
that's adjusted we can simply adjust our
slab on the 3D by selecting the blue
outer lines and adjusting as we see fit
now I don't actually know what the
windows are like around the building so
what I'm simply going to do is Select
that same window by pressing alt or
options copy the parameters across and
I'm going to reduce that window to three
meters what I then want to do is select
one of the outside nodes go to my
multiply tool on the right hand side and
distribute let's say about six copies
across this entire project so clicking
once more on one of the nodes I'm going
to distribute 25 meters across I want to
repeat that same step on the wall on the
opposite side back to 3D you'll see that
our shape is actually starting to take
some form which is looking really really
impressive so now we want to actually
focus on the architecture on the outside
now because you've made it this far in
the video you'll be excited to know that
down below in the description there is a
Discord link it'll allow you to join a
Discord Community 100 completely free so
that you can talk all things
architecture with people just like you
from all over the world if you want
access to this arcad file in this video
make sure you sign up to the patreon
which will then send you to the Discord
chat to also talk with everybody but
also again exclusive access to all
things archicad let's come up to our
first floor plan and think about this
for a second basically what they've done
is constructed a full project going from
floor to ceiling up and then offset an
external skin they've either battened it
out or they've used some sort of top
hats but in this instance all I'm going
to do is show you another wall so now
what we can do is select multiple walls
click on the outside go to our offset
all edges tool adjust out as we see fit
press the option or alt button push that
out 350 millimeters and then repeat the
same process for that front wall so
coming back into 3D now we'll see we
have this outer skin that's hovering
over the top of our entire facade if we
select all of those outer skins we can
go command T and then we can change our
actual materials so I'm just going to
Simply paint that Black Ivory for this
instance it is a textured wood finish
but we're not going to go into too much
texture detail in this video here now
let's focus on this small little V cut
out at the very front if we come back to
our first floor plan there are multiple
ways to do this the easiest in my
opinion is to use the roof tool so if we
use the roof tool and create a basically
an invisible intersecting object what we
can do is start by creating a single
pane roof duplicating it on both sides
and enjoining it exactly where we need
coming into 3D we'll see again that
we've started to create this roof
structure so let's open up our settings
again let's change this entirely so it
doesn't really matter what it is I only
need it to be one millimeter thick and I
don't want it to be seen so I'm going to
change and override all of my materials
to air next I'm going to press ok to
finish that off and we're going to see
that we can have our roof basically
cutting that outline entirely I think
that pitch is a little bit higher so I'm
going to drop that to about 15 maybe 18
degrees right click on this wall connect
solid AMOLED operations and then I'm
going to select my two roof panels go
out as operator Subtract with downwards
Extrusion and hit execute now I can
close that panel and you can quickly see
that we've created exactly what we've
been looking for now because that roof
pitch is slightly larger this window
we're going to Simply increase the
height of that window to create that
visual effect we are seeing in this
example image as well now as all of this
comes back together let's jump to our
roof plan let's right click show us
Trace reference on our first floor and
create a brand new roof structure this
roof structure is obviously using the
external wall on the outside so we are
going to draw one brand new roof on the
outside Walls by simply drawing that
roof in we can come back to 3D now we
can see we've created our beautiful
black roof let's simply override all of
those textures again we're going to name
it Black Ivory to match our cladding
again we're not going into textures
claddings or anything like that we are
going to select our two
external walls drag them all the way up
right click connect solid element
operations again repeat our steps we did
previously this time with an upwards
Extrusion and click execute so far so
good our project is starting to come
together it is definitely looking a lot
taller than it is in this image so if
you wanted to reduce the overall Heights
in your command 7 area to two five or
even two seven you're most welcome to
but there isn't too much left in this
design to make it look as beautiful as
this image does so let's now jump back
to our first floor plan now we have to
introduce this large section up the top
that is breaking out and creating this
beautiful Vista of a window so let's
start by introducing a brand new wall
let's step that out 500 millimeters and
adjust that one and a half meters either
side of the middle of this building now
this gives us this shape at the front
but it does not give us the shape at the
top so we want to also extend our two
walls roughly to the of this building
depending on where they are jump back
into 3D to understand what we've drawn
select all three of our walls and extend
their height we want to extend our
height to roughly the middle of this
roof pitch so clicking OK there and you
can see that we started to create our
boxed out shape now this shape doesn't
start from the first floor like all the
other walls do so it's similar to how
we've just extended up we're also going
to extend it from the bottom we're going
to start it roughly in the middle of
that space now if we come back into our
first floor plan we can go down hold the
option button over one of our Windows
below come back up introduce a nice
large Square window into that space come
into 3D so we can adjust it exactly
where we need to place it in the middle
and then we only have two windows left
so as easy as that first little window
was to replicate we're going to go back
down by pressing command down command
back up after we've selected our little
window there we're going to introduce
one small little square window over this
side I think it's probably about 500 by
500 millimeters it's not a very big
window and we're going to repeat the
same process somewhere about here it's
coming back into 3D we can see that our
windows are all too low so we're going
to select both windows adjust the height
of them a little bit and also adjust the
size they're definitely larger than I
anticipated so let's go one meter by one
meter on our design adjust again
perfectly where we need to see them
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed the video make sure you check
out the playlist to the side of me it
has more great architectural content if
you love the video make sure you smash
that subscribe button down below and
while you're there there are some great
architectural downloads as well
available in the description below like
I said that's it for me so I will see
you next Monday